last month's Italian earthquake couldn't
have come at a worse time
the economy has stalled yet again and
poverty is at a 10-year high my guest is
the country's Europe Minister Sandro
gutsy and the pressure from poor
economic results and the rising populist
movement how long can his government
survive
Santo grazie
welcome to conflict zone let's start if
we made with the recent earthquakes the
sense of tragedy the sense of loss has
given way in some quarters to anger
anger that more wasn't done to ensure
that the buildings were quake-proof
why didn't the government do this why
didn't they do more well we should do
more and we want to do more but it's a
big failing isn't it is clear that in
the past
Italy is more know too much and prevent
it not enough this is still the case
well it is why we proposed a big plan
called the cars Italia Italia Italian
home exactly because we want to avoid in
the future this kind of tragedy and this
is a major project to save lives to save
goods but also mean to guarantee a
better future for not only our people
but our beautiful country why don't you
strengthen the penalties involved
because your own statistics office says
unlawful construction is of dimensions
unparalleled in other advanced economies
yes people think here they can get away
with it yeah another every Bardem of the
past and this is why we have asked a
very good magistrate was done an
excellent job for the Expo in Milan
Rafaela Cantona with the chair of the
new anti-corruption authorities to
verify everything has been done and to
verify what we are going to do to
rebuild because on this again we don't
want to commit the mistake done in the
past but you need new sanctions if you
were serious about this we would see you
rushing new legislation through
Parliament higher penalties and enforce
more enforcement why are we not seeing
because I don't think that the problem
in Italy our laws probably got too many
laws the issue is to enforce and
properly in for the flow law we have and
this is what we are going to do you
won't take on the big vested interests
will you you won't take on the Mafia
that is going to cream off some of the
money
that's going to be given for
reconstruction this is a perennial
problem here you've closed 200 municipal
councils in Italy over the last 25 years
because of infiltration by the Mafia you
can't stop it can you
of course we can and of course we can
face the important project in our
country without running the risk of
mafia action once again all the world
watched what we do we do all for the
expo in Milan
big scandal of corruption be scandal of
mafia action around it we run the risk
of not having the World Exhibition in
Milan we file we fought against
organized crime we found again voted
against corruption we we organized a
major event we want to build on this
experience because that proves that we
can fight the illness of the past and we
can show that Italy is a changing
country but your judges say something
different just five months ago Supreme
Court judge Camilo de vigo said he
believes corruption has been getting
worse in recent years he says the
politicians haven't stopped stealing
they've stopped being ashamed of it he
said now they blatantly claim a right to
do what they used to do secretly that's
not getting better this is a major
embarrassment for your government
here's a senior judge we're in court
judge I give you I give you some figures
I don't want to open a debate and out a
debate with their camara de Vigo who is
now the chair of the judges syndicate
what he's talking about
yeah yeah he knows what he's talking
about and also know that for example we
have reduced by 40 percent the fraud
against the Italian in the new budget in
the use of public funds only last year
and this is a major step ahead what I
don't share about that because you it
that he want to condemn in our country
to some illnesses of the past we think
that this country can change that this
country is changing and we are proving
that we can do much better and notably
in a legal way even though he says
things are still getting worse because
your country
consistently ranked as the most corrupt
country within the eurozone according to
Transparency International yeah this is
not changing this is changing and this
but you still and you're still ranked
that's the most this is changing and and
it is why we took a we on this on the
fight against corruption we introduced
new legislation to fight against
corruption we create an anti-corruption
authorities and we are getting results
okay let's let's look at the brighter
future that you're talking about as far
as the economy is concerned growth has
stalled for the latest quarter zero
growth in the second quarter of this
year and poverty is at a 10-year high so
your perspectives don't look that great
- well I mean in the last trimester
Italy has done zero growth France has
done zero growth the eurozone has done
0.3% I wouldn't take it that as a
specific Italian problem you're always
in the bottom a gouramis in the bottom
six or seven countries when it comes to
grow at the beginning of our GAO and we
started from a minus two percent and I
think that already from - % - resistor a
plus a 0.8% of last year and working to
really boost growth is something that is
already an improvement of course we are
not satisfied but you're the third
August economy in the eurozone minister
and running at half the average rate of
growth in the eurozone half the average
ray you take GDP growth in the first
quarter of 2016 average in the eurozone
was not 0.6 your figure half of that not
point three yes of course a country
which has not as has never done serious
reform for the last 15 years a country
which has suffered more than others
because of wrong European therapy a
country which is starting now to having
major structural reform like the reform
the labor market reform of justice the
reform public administration we hope if
we win the referendum and made your
constitutional reform it is clear that
you can
respect it early to perform as other
country with this with this backlog of
work that it hasn't been done and that
we have done in this too one day and I
feel we're going to continue to do it
but you've said targets that you're not
going to meet are you I mean you would
need to grow by 1.3 percent in the last
two quarters of this year to meet your
goals for 2016 you're not going to grow
at 1.3 percent but I felt final quote no
nobody is going to confirm the economic
forecasts of April and this is not the
Italian government saying it if you look
at the International Monetary found it
look at the OECD they are all saying
that they there will be economic
slowdown compared to the economic force
that April has given you a worse
forecasting for the other countries in
the Eurozone your economy it said won't
return to pre 2008 levels until the mid
2020s by which time the other eurozone
countries it said will be 20 to 25
percent larger so your forecast is
noticeably worse than for the other
countries isn't it that that must be
seen we are we got better figure but the
point that I mean we are doing the
reform effort which nobody has done
before and Italy needs many structural
reforms some of them have been taken and
they are going to be implemented been
implemented some other still needs to be
taken we cannot solve all the problem
that we have a commute accumulated in
almost two decades in two years and this
is why we are so determined in moving
ahead with our reform effort you have
two lost decades of growth according to
the IMF and any recovery in the Italian
economy is likely they say to be fragile
and prolonged but this is why we insist
on the fact that there are two main
macro causes for this Italian delay the
first I told you the time that Italy is
wasted the second wrong therapy at
European level your Prime Minister has
said also a third one the uncertainty
over the British
exit from the European Union but all the
all the major Indian economic
organization are saying that the
slowdown in the last month is due to
three main reasons the first is the
terrorism terrorist attack the second is
the migratory crisis the third is the
uncertainty around brakes it is not only
Prime Minister rein to say this no but
all the major economic organization was
say but what he did say was that the
English are the ones who will feel the
damage most it's it's almost as if he
wants the British to suffer as a result
there is no revenge or less some giving
sentiment it is clear that I mean we
fully respect the choice of the Brits we
need now to focus on what needs to be
done among 27 and notably within the
eurozone and a new investment policy to
boost growth but it would be very good
for us the British suffered wouldn't it
no why what if they make it what if they
make a go of it what if their economy
grows what if their employment grows
what if all the economic indicators turn
green how are you going to persuade your
citizens here who are labouring with
eleven and a half percent unemployment
that it's worth staying in the EU and
that makes your job that much harder
doesn't it
my job is a very difficult one the job
of any when the British success would
make it even more do I wish all the
success of the Brits I do not believe I
do not believe that there is the right
choice I fully respect the British
choice I think that it is a deeply wrong
choice and I think that in the medium
run Britain will suffer from that and we
regret it where it doesn't have the
problems you have it doesn't have eleven
and a half percent unemployment its
employment levels is five percent
unemployment level is five percent
it doesn't have three hundred and sixty
billion euros of bad debts in its
banking does it it's public sector debt
to GDP ratios nowhere near the hundred
and thirty two percent that you have if
you and your Prime Minister says
the Brits are gonna suffer most it
doesn't look like I think I think that
the Brits are going to suffer from for
leaving the biggest market in the world
they're going to suffer because they
will not have any possibility of having
an influence ad they had got on a key
decision making process on issue which
are very relevant to employment and
economic growth in in the Union if we
have one hundred thirty percent of
public debt it is not because of the
European Union because of your
responsible policies that in Italy we
have done notably in the eighties and my
generation is carrying a very a very
heavy weight from those irresponsible
policies but what you'd blow off on that
what you blame for your problems partly
is austerity isn't it
of course austere your finance minister
said and you've been complaining about
austerity since since 2014 but the irony
is that you seem to want closer
political union closer union with the
body that's putting you into austerity
that you are chafing against that you
hate so much the union has been in the
lost austerity decade technocratic and
not political as just focused on very
tight roles as totally neglected the
social impact of those austerity
measures this has been has got a
devastating effect on destroying growth
like absolutely you says destroy and and
III and the and the the fact that after
ten years of those recipe Europe is not
doing well and those country where
applied this recipe the most are not
doing well demo Germany is doing well
then well Germany is doing well this was
your complaint that it's 28 countries or
too soon to be 27 countries not just one
this was your Prime Minister's complaint
well I do believe that Germany has
mostly benefited from the euro as most
benefited from the policies which been
well being followed in the eurozone and
I think that now it is the time also to
accommodate the need of country needs to
relaunch growths and I think that from
one side the quantitative easing of the
European Central Bank is very good for
the eurozone but this is not enough what
we say in that we need to do more at
national European level for a new
investment policy but you also supervise
empire black investment boys you
disagree on so much with the with other
countries in the you've had open rouse
with Germany you've had open rounds with
the European Commission there's a lot of
bad blood between Italy and other
members of the EU it's not that I
wouldn't I wouldn't say that at the
moment I would say at the moment the
relations between Italy and Germany are
good as the last Italy Germany summit
proved I think that we are converted
recited some slogans with each other and
a few clichés it didn't you couldn't say
good relations really where did you give
an example on a new stronger political
convergence between Terry and Germany my
great my migration policy heo level and
also the need the fact that we all agree
that we need to do more and better with
the investment plan the so-called yoga
plan and the fact that we need to do
more for youth policies also at a
European level but in January
youngja criticized your Prime Minister
openly he said I think he's wrong to
offend the Commission at every
opportunity I don't see why he does it
and your Prime Minister replied we won't
be intimidated Italy deserves respect
it's pretty sad when it gets back all
that level is here it was it was a start
it was an original way of understanding
each other because that belonged to the
recent past but misunderstood a new
phase and the decision the Commission
took on the Italian budget the decision
they commit the proposal the Commission
made on migration they proposed the
Commission made on relations between
Europe and Africa all go toward the
right direction and I we think that we
need to foster our bilateral relations I
would think that since things has
changed a lot since January even even
though this seems like a body which is
on the brink of falling apart and I say
that because Germany's deputy Chancellor
Sigma Gabriel born just days ago that
unless the British exit from the EU was
handled properly the European Union he
said would go down the drain it's that
fragile that you go down the drain I
think if you get this way I think that
the Union is going through a very
delicate phase I think that the Union
cannot afford effort to remain in the
status quo and I think the status quo
could be the beginning of European
disintegration whereas what we need is
to relaunch on a new basis the European
integration process is why immediately
we have to give ants for proper hands
for efficient transfer on growth
security and youth and next year we have
to think of a new political pact for the
Union for ever closer Union but these
are not new tablets this you're not
saying anything new that hasn't been you
said you don't need to hasn't been said
for years you don't need to be original
you just need to implement what we say
ok but you know perfectly well when
you're talking about the calls for unity
peace freedom getting dreams back this
is not a Europe that knows how to unite
there is no unity on the migrant crisis
look at southern Europe Eastern Europe
for instance where was the Czech
Republic when it came to wanting unity
it has relocated for people okay
yes Slovakia has relocated three hungary
has relocated none Poland has relocated
so there's no unity on the migrant issue
and you're not going to change their
minds they're certain about this I think
that that is shameful I think that it is
shameful that after such a long
negotiation do we done it properly in
the inter for respect of the treaty
we're in a democratic way we discuss
among government in the Council of
Ministers
our direct elected member of European
Parliament took a decision and then
there are four or five countries were
Putin who are paying a lip service to
the sea a decision Democrat retaken view
of today this is what you have this is
why I'm telling you
that we have to get out of the status
quo and certainly we to get out on
status quo we need we need both
pragmatist and vision but you know the
litany will implement countries to do it
and you don't have that even fighting
terrorism you don't have the political
will to exchange information the head of
Europe all last year said that when it
came to exchanging information in Europe
security information Europe was a black
exactly and a call and the result of
this absurdity but is it is clear that
you are facing transnational threats and
you have to respond to transnational
threat with the new transnational policy
at European level on terrorists on
migration on finance regulation there is
that the fact that we have been so shy
and we have lacked a political wind in
the previous what is the result
growing populism disaffection 48% of
Italian saying in May that they would
like to leave the European Union it is
why we cannot afford the stuff maybe you
should let the ending well I mean I
think that we should get out let me go
no because I love too much my country to
let my country go to war suicide so I
think that at the best that your country
is in a terrible state as you blame a
lot of it on the EU well the the you is
the you the policy with the u.s.
following the fury in the recent years
bear a part of the responsibility for
this growing euro skepticism apart but
if if the EU does not have common
solutions to common problems
what is its legitimacy it has no
legitimacy does it are you saying that
you are explaining the reason for you
have no organization in the reason for
the lack of legitimate EU and this is
why we are saying it is time to deliver
and it is possible it is possible to
deliver immediately on the issues which
are at the center of citizens worries
which are again I repeat and this should
be done from here to the Bratislava
summit and from here to the end of the
year we need the new growth policy a new
in
and policy we knew we need to do
something serious about security and
your chances of getting it are pretty
slim I want to look at one issue the
migrant issue and in particular the
shabby deal that the EU has done with
Turkey which is busy falling apart how
is it that on the one hand the EU can
say you're anti-terrorist law Turkish
anti-terrorist law is too harsh and yet
you are still continuing to negotiate
with the country that has collectively
junked human rights arrested thousands
of lawyers academics judges police if
the EU had some respect self-respect it
would get up and leave the table
wouldn't it I wouldn't keep negotiating
but country that does that too we have
been very clear we have been written and
the Whopper Minister was very clear also
when we are negotiating the migration
agreement between chicken anyway and the
you which is so far is working which is
so far is working and we were very clear
that I mean there is no place ministers
400 200 400 people have been relocated
as a result it's not working it is it is
what it is working between Turkey and
Greece it what it is working at the
border with images from the Aegean
islands they were claimed to be it is
working so far but we have been very
clear there is no place in the present
and the future of Europe for country who
do not respect rule of law for country
do not respect fundamental rights and
this is is true for everybody even for
country within the European Union
industry was for Turkey and yet you're
about to reward them with visa-free
access to Europe Martin Schultz
president of the European Parliament
said okay we have a little difficulty
this was this week in Ankara he said we
have some difficulties of the
anti-terrorist law but that doesn't mean
we can't do a deal he wasn't ruling out
giving Turkey this turkey visa-free
access rewarding the human rights abuses
with visa-free access to Europe on visa
liberalisation things are very clear
there are specific right here to comply
this not a Poli
your decision there are more than 70
criteria to comply you happy to agree
war and human rights and since Turkey or
other countries whereas apply for visa
liberalization I have not complied with
all the criteria it is not possible to
hide and then it is also you need also
the approval European Parliament and of
course the European Parliament also will
make its own assessments so far the
European Parliament has been very clear
on the need to comply with all the
specific criteria which are foreseen
let's talk about specific instances not
just Turkey but I want to go back to the
Italian student the student giulio
regeni
who was tortured and murdered in Egypt
at the beginning of the year I'm sure
you'll recall the case he's a student he
was a student at Cambridge University
his body was found with evidence of
torture it's clear that the Egyptian
authorities have provided no convincing
explanation for why this is done and his
mother posed a question post a question
to the Italian and the British
government as far as I know she didn't
get any answer why if you still treating
Egypt as a friend
why do friends kill each other's
children don't you think she deserves an
answer to that question is their
announcement is why our Prime Minister
our Foreign Minister was directly
dealing with this issue have been very
clear with the Egyptian Authority and
Egyptian government we want all the
truth and they take no notice society
called tragically they they take no
notice via we are we are insisting on
this language so why no sanctions
against against now we we want to focus
on the truth and they think that our
prime minister is taking very seriously
as ice taken personally very seriously
very beginning and his continued to work
the family has called for sanctions why
no sanctions against Egypt we are going
where we are we are going to see we are
going to see what the we want truth and
we want a so funny if you were serious
you would impose sanctions I I would
prefer to to repeat what is our official
position therefore our prime ministers
say we want all the truth from education
what is more and is know something which
idea direct
most of what is more important the
torture and murder of one of your
citizens or some business deals that the
EU the EU is pushing ahead with this
association agreement with Egypt for us
from the Manta right and rule of law
come first and this is why it is our
government which during the semester of
the present the European Union has
launched a new rule of law process
within the Union because we think that
if there is something on which we have
to focus as European something that is
three trillion rupiah identity's rule of
law fundamental right this true within
the Union this must be true more and
more in our relations of proper with
giulio regeni wants more from you and
there and they they deserve more and we
want to have all the truths about this
tragic whole event so jakotsu good to
have you on conflict zone thank you very
much thank you